[Musique]
[Rires]
alors toute l'équipe des affamés je suis
quand même très ému de voir vous êtes
manie possible au repas les à
l'intérieur via la réalisatrice luan jeu
justement je vais te laisser présenter
toute ta bande dans le film de copains
du coup il ya ma mère a bien sûr c'est
elle qui dans le film s'appelle mode et
qui est la soeur donc de françois deux
blocs qui dans le film est mon amoureux
et 116 lucas le reste de tout ce monde
extraordinaire et donc la coloc et puis
à ma gauche la réalisatrice la chef
d'orchestre de toute cette joyeuse bande
les affres étoiles 7 colloque c'était
comme une famille et qui dit famille dit
on vous dit quoi c'est parce que je
baise bas c'est quoi ton délire
est-ce que je base ma non tu bosse bien
et bien sûr tu ce buzz d'or lui c'est
arthur ça faisait cinq ans qu'il
travaillait dans une banque
moi je serais vous je voudrais pas un
petit chien jamais pour john pleine nuit
il réussissait à y trouver son compte
spacieuse pour caroline quant à elle son
emploi du moment ne lui permettait pas
vraiment de mettre ses compétences à
profit de prison
capacité de concentration proche du
chaton qui nous explique pourquoi ça
s'appelle les affamés enfin de quoi ces
jeunes crise pourquoi tu as la dalle
moi j'ai la dalle parce que j'ai droit à
un avenir radieux
j'ai le droit d'être heureuse d'avoir un
boulot qui me correspond
qui me plaît bien aussi là je me battais
compas tous les diplômes soient à la
hauteur de mes diplômes crise est là
surdiplômés la coloc
elle a un bac + 5 en marketing
international a suivi la voie
comme beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui et
elle a même difficile mais à la fin du
set voyait rien et voilà c'est ça qui
est une viande est galvaudé aujourd'hui
je me bouge je trouve un taf ridant tac
au tac
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai compris
les jeunes c'est pas juste une catégorie
d'âge fait une classe sociale on nous
devons tout sans rien nous donner en
échange aux commandes pour récurer des
chiottes pour faire des fichiers excel
jusqu'à pas d'heure mais rythme dans la
bande qui a vécu sade d'enchaîner des
petits boulots de c'est ce que j'allais
dire à par luan qui a une carrière et du
liant les très jeunes
j'ai commencé trop trop jeune pour avoir
pour avoir vécu ça et c'est la chance
que jacques mai mais pour autant je sais
très bien pas de pain on parle moi j'ai
commencé un peu aussi mon premier film
donc j'avais 14 ans quand j'ai tourné
mais ensuite j'ai fait beaucoup de
petits boulots je travaille dans la
restauration je travaille dans la
manutention j'ai travaillé non dans la
livraison entre autres
à côté de ça j'ai fait des films qui ont
plus ou moins marché certains plus que
d'autres mais j'arrivais de servir des
verres à des gens qui me disent je t'ai
vu tu parles
d'accord on expliquer moi la préparation
pour le tournage parce que dans le dans
le film vous avez vite et bon quasiment
tous en colloques et vous êtes vrais
faisait vraiment fait une coloc la voix
de tourner enfin départ on est parti
sans pas trop monter lui non pas contre
en fait moi j'avais un peu peur a pu
très vite ils m'ont la santé oms et bien
entendu c'était c'était chef des
endroits qui est le colloque le plus
terrible comment ça dort tranquillement
dans la vraie vie dans la vraie vie
c'est rabat ça va mais pourquoi rask non
ou alors c'est rafa et moi ensemble
pourquoi on a on a fait des fêtes
ils ont fait des blagues à moi surtout
là avec des nombreuses dès mon retour
mais on est le plus gros mais bon le
coup terrible ici rien de black 2
non non non non non non non tu balances
à cheval en selle sur google on en
balance une dent balancement des deux
alors votre sinon vous le jouez à
chifoumi mais là je me suis dit si vous
me si vous me ils m'ont fait croire
qu'ils avaient une histoire ce qui est
parfait c'était complètement fou mais
sauf qu'ils ont été amenés à tourner en
rond et effectivement moi j'étais en
stress parce que c'était pour du tout
comme ça que ça devait se passer et on
avait parlé plus du tout sauf qu'au bout
d'un moment on a vu que ça envoie cette
relève les parties d'avoir laissé une
balle est alors j'avoue questionnaire
pour vous avant de se quitter
[Musique]
la phrase qu'on vous a le plus travaillé
pendant votre jeunesse va le le c'est
normal mais rejette nos jeunes samaté
jeune moi ça va arriver at the table
tient de la drogue tout le temps tiens
toi prêt
le cliché sur les jeunes que vous ne
supportez pas fait des anciens ouais ça
m'a tellement marina bonsoir je pense
que vous en pensez à la plagne hantise
[Rires]
c'est soit la chose la plus romantique
que vous avez pu faire pour séduire
quelqu'un je me suis embrouillé avec
quelqu'un qui était dans une ville
complètement différente à trois heures
de là où j'étais
j'étais dans un taxi et j'ai dit aux
taxis on va gare de lyon est jugée pris
en main et j'ai débarqué sur un coup de
tête qui avant de se quitter à une
goulotte envoyé jason moi j'ai pris un
avion aussi mais moi je suis parti au
brésil donc ça m'a coûté 2000 euros -
gare de lyon merci beaucoup les affamés
on va se quitter avec un petit show
collégiale mais un petit chat affamé
plein de points
[Rires]